[Musique]
parce que chaque fois qu'il nous arrive
d'aller en Coupe du Monde nous
représentons bien l'Afrique nous ne
représentons pas que l'Afrique au niveau
du football dans tous les sports nous
sommes présents vous voyez Nganou
champion du monde vous voyez au tennis y
Noa actuellement au basket il a fait
très très mal avec 7 points jelite par
que chez nous au Cameroun on trouve tout
tout genre de nourriture tout genre de
musique tout et on a le ment c'est la
quoi on on se retrouve partout dans le
monde donc on est un continent continent
voilà c'est ça quoi on a du pétrole on a
de la boxite on a du du de l'or du
diamant et tout ça là donc tout ce qu'il
y a dans certains pays nous on a tout ça
chez nous c'est le monde en miniature le
Cameroun c'est pour ça le le c'est pour
ça le surnom de continent les
Camerounais ils sont à la NASA on est en
Afrique on est les meilleur et tout
voilà c'est pas du tout présent tu